what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Captain America 4 Brave New World
based off of what we've heard so far is
shaping up to be a phenomenal movie
knock on wood not trying to jinx it but
from what we've heard from the cast and
from insiders it sounds like it's going
to be pretty dang good and a recent
report suggests that in a way Captain
America 4 Brave New World is going to
pick up where the last Captain America
film left off and of course the last
Captain America film that we got was
Captain America Civil War what's being
reported now is that Captain America
Brave New World will serve as a sort of
cataclys that may lead to a Civil War 2
project meaning The Avengers team or
heroes are going to be in Conflict
they'll be going up against each other
and we're hearing that this will take
place before the Avengers projects come
around so before Avengers King Dynasty
and before Avengers Secret Wars so a lot
to break down in this video but if
you're new be sure to subscribe grabs
you don't miss any of the MCU news and
if you subscribe and leave a comment on
our videos you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items a winner gets to
pick one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month so this is coming
from a very reliable source Alex P over
at thecosmiccircus.com somebody on
Twitter asked him if he's heard much
about the Hulk or if he's heard anything
about the Hulk and he said there really
isn't much to say about Banner
specifically at this moment because of
the strikes obviously referring to the
writers and the actor strikes going on
right now but he continued to say all
I've heard so far is that what happens
in Brave New World becomes part of the
cataclys that may lead to a Civil War 2
scenario prior to the Avengers projects
now the reason that he's saying may lead
is because of the strikes keep in mind a
lot of info is coming out recently and
they might decide to redo it after the
strikes are over Marvel is having a lot
of time to think right now and when the
writers and the actors come back from
the strikes and get get ready to work
again on these scripts that they're
currently writing Kevin feige might come
in and say Hey I've thought of something
different we're going a different
direction but it sounds like as of right
now there is going to be a lot of
conflict in Captain America Brave New
World and not just between Captain
America Sam Wilson's Captain America and
Thunderbolt Ross AKA Red Hulk but
conflict between Heroes and one can
imagine how this could come into play
because Captain America is wanting to go
up against Thunderbolt Ross who is going
to be the president of the United States
in Captain America Brave New World so
you have to imagine that's not something
that some of the heroes take pretty
lightly we've heard that Sam is going to
start recruiting other Heroes for his
cause to go up against Thunderbolt Ross
and it sounds like not all of them are
going to agree with him and side with
him and it honestly sounds like they are
basically setting up the same story that
was set up in the first Civil War in the
MCU and basically it sounds like we're
gonna have another sokovia chords now
they got rid of sokovia chords because
all the heroes saved half the universe
in Avengers end game we found out in
Phase 4 there are no more sokovia
Accords however it does kind of look
like the sokovia chords could make a
return especially with Thunderbolt Ross
now being president you know he was
behind the sokovia chords all along and
he wants to be in control over the
heroes which is why we're going to get
the Thunderbolts team eventually but if
you think about the events that have
currently happened in the MCU
specifically involving the Scarlet Witch
we have had Heroes do bad things we've
had Wanda take over Westview then not to
mention in Multiverse of Madness of
course she went up against all the
sorcerers but she summoned a demon at
Doctor Strange and Wong then had to
fight alongside of America Chavez kind
of then we add Hawkeye going around with
Kate bishop and he caused some
destruction as well plus obviously
Falcon at the time now Captain America
caused a lot of commotion with Bucky and
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier so
since they got rid of the sokovia Accord
some of the heroes haven't exactly kept
a low profile and you know Thunderbolt
Ross has been paying attention the
entire time you know he's just looking
for a reason to bring the sokovia
Accords back so he can control the
heroes himself and what sounds like is
going to be the tip of the iceberg that
finally causes him to go these heroes
are not good is when and if the reports
are true Sam Wilson's Captain America
does go up against Thunderbolt Ross and
there's a lot to talk about here but
first a big thank you to DraftKings for
sponsoring this video DraftKings
rainmakers football is back for its
second season and it's bigger and better
than ever before if you head to
draftkings.com audio you can sign up to
play rainmakers today using Code Cosmic
for your share of over 30 million
dollars in prizes this football season
and this week new customers can claim
their first pack of digital players
cards for free to get started playing
rainmakers football is simple each
DraftKings digital card represents an
athlete and scores points based on their
real world performance draft them into
weekly contests for your shot at a share
of 30 million dollars in prizes and one
of the best parts is rainmakers contests
require no fee to join as long as you
have enough cards to complete a lineup
rip packs build your collection and earn
big rewards so wondering how to get
started new customers can visit
draftkings.com audio today and use promo
code Cosmic to claim a free starter pack
again only at draftkings.com audio with
code Cosmic now Captain America going up
against Thunderbolt Ross and getting
sort of an Avengers team is also backed
up by a report from can we get some
toast who stated to put it simply
Captain America has been benched
president Ross thinks Sam's time as
Captain America is better suited for
publicity while Sam knows he's meant to
be in the field and that is just the tip
of the iceberg to their conflict so this
is obviously going to be the breaking
point Captain America our new Captain
America and his newly recruited Avengers
team going into conflict with the
president of the United States it's an
not a very good look even though we know
the Avengers mean well and the heroes
are doing what they believe is right
Thunderbolt Ross can spin this in
whatever way he deems fit he is going to
be the president of the United States
and it's very clear from this report
that he wants Sam and the Avengers out
of the way he doesn't want to deal with
them he wants to control his own group
and that is going to be the Thunderbolts
and then he also is going to become Red
Hulk himself from what we've heard what
was very hinted at by The Insider Daniel
rbk is that Thunderbolt Ross is
seemingly going to have a heart attack
in this situation he most likely to keep
himself from dying is going to reach for
that super soldier serum that will in
turn turn him into the Hulk but will
save his life and obviously the serum is
going to be a little bit different since
he's going to be red and not green but
now you have somebody who is the
president of the United States who is as
strong as a Hulk who wants the Avengers
out of the way and he has a lot of power
not only does he have the power as the
pre president of the United States to
basically do anything he is now also
going to have the physical power of a
Hulk and you could probably see how some
Avengers some of the heroes new and old
will have a problem with this going up
against the president of the United
States who has a lot of power and could
potentially in a way ban superheroes and
this is what could lead to that next
civil war event because some heroes are
probably going to argue that some of the
actions of some of the heroes haven't
exactly been good the Scarlet Witch is a
perfect example she essentially held a
whole entire town hostage and sword got
involved so the government knows all
about it and they're probably keeping
tabs on everything that's happened and
if you look at it from a public point of
view that is really scary a hero who has
vast and incredibly strong Powers took
an entire town hostage controlling their
minds that is super scary to a civilian
who has no powers whatsoever and they
would definitely fear being in that
situation themselves and this is kind of
how the fear of the X-Men is in Marvel
Comics as well and what we've seen in
the X-Men movies before the fear of
mutants or anybody with power simply
using those powers to do whatever they
want so this is where the conflict
between the heroes comes in the conflict
of one doing what is right and two kind
of keeping the ones who don't do what's
right in check and kind of ironically
enough this kind of has to do with the
Scarlet Witch again but of course it's
not just her and I do believe she's
going to have a very good redeeming Arc
in the Multiverse Saga in fact I think
she's going to be one of the key
components to actually fixing the
destroyed Multiverse but it looks like
we could have another civil war leading
up to the Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars so really it does feel a lot
like the first Captain America Civil War
going into Avengers Infinity war and
then into Avengers end game so it should
be quite a big event much like last time
but let me know who you think is going
to be against each other Heroes wise in
the comments down below who do you think
is going to be on Captain America's team
and who you think is going to be against
him if this conflict Civil War 2 really
does happen in the MCU let us know all
your thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on the latest MCU news you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
foreign